well I will never let happen
is a repeat of what happened in coal
mining
where an industry came to an end and
nobody had planned for the future and
we're still living with the consequences
we cannot allow that to happen and I
think there is an opportunity now
to seize the next generation of jobs
in nuclear in new nuclear in Renewables
across the country and there's a race on
it's going on around look at the
inflation reduction act in America look
at the eu's response there's a race on
for the next generation of jobs and we
need to be in that race
the wind turbines in white leaves were
not built in Britain because we didn't
get ahead of the game we cannot let that
happen again so we're going to seize
that opportunity to get those jobs in
Renewables and I have estimated there's
hundreds of thousands of jobs to be had
future jobs 50 000 in Scotland 50 000
jobs in Scotland and we can use the
skills that we've got we can deploy
those skills and we can make sure
through GB energy through procurement
that those jobs are in the places that
need them because we don't want to
repeat the error of saying you've got to
move you've got to go we don't need to
come to you to your community you can we
can let you wither we will never repeat
that but if we don't seize that
opportunity
if we just sit back and wait without
acting now on our green Prosperity plan
then I genuinely think Congress that
future Generations will never forgive us
for repeating the mistake was made when
the coal mines were closed down